ce qui concerne l'environnement et et à
besançon le super rectorat et à besançon
la direccte est à besançon donc voilà
simplement faut pas se plaindre tous les
jours il faut pas se comporter comme des
comme des goujats voilà on n'accepte pas
ils nous traitent de demeurer moi je ne
crois pas les mots du capitaine haddock
madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
bourgogne franche comté où vous venez de
le voir ou de le revoir le ton est monté
ces dernières semaines entre les deux
principales villes de la région dijon et
deux ans sur la guéguerre est reparti de
plus belle depuis que le ministre de la
justice a décidé d'implanter le tribunal
de commerce spécialisé à dijon et non
pas chez sa voisine franc comtoise à
leurs querelles d'un autre âge
impossibilité de travailler ensemble
simple emballement médiatique que
faudrait-il être en place pour une bonne
coopération et dans quels domaines c'est
de tout cela dont nous allons parler
dans cette voie est libre commune à
france 3 bourgogne et à france 3 franche
comté jérémy cheval bonjour bonjour à
tous et je vous présente tout de suite
nos invités des élus et des acteurs du
monde économique des deux villes laurent
grandguillaume député socialiste de
côte-d'or vous êtes élu municipal à
dijon précise que vous avez grandi à
besançon ce sera peut-être important à
prendre en compte par l'eba face à vous
eric alauzet et élu municipal également
mais à besançon vous êtes-vous député
écologiste du doubs également sur ce
plateau françois berthelon président du
ceser le comité économique le conseil
économique social et environnemental de
bourgogne franche comté qui en quelques
sortes siffler la fin de la partie il ya
quelques jours vous nous direz si vous
êtes larbitre de ceux de cette bataille
entre les deux villes et puis un
bisontin également dominique leroy vous
êtes président de la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie du doubs et vous avez
grandi à dijon c'est ce swing et a dit
je vous êtes né à dijon
voilà et puis vous le savez cette
émission c'est aussi la vôtre vous
pouvez poser vos questions interpeller
nos invités sur la page de l'émission la
voix est libre à la fois sur le site de
bourgogne et sur le site de
franche-comté vos questions nous les
recevons sur ce plateau et on
interpellera on se fera worley avec eric
vos questions auprès nos invités et puis
évidemment vous pouvez pour réagir et
commenter l'émission sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le mot diez lvl bfc comme
la voix est libre
bourgogne franche comté alors c'est donc
l'implantation à dijon du tribunal de
commerce spécialisé qui a mis le feu aux
poudres le décret ministériel est paru
le 26 février depuis les noms d'oiseaux
volent entre dijon et besançon
et pourtant est ce que ce n'est pas une
décision de bon sens pour reprendre le
mot du président de la cci de côte-d'or
pour ce tribunal finalement qui va ne
s'occuper que des grandes entreprises de
la région
on commence laurent grandguillaume oui
je pense que vous ferez il ya des débats
il ya des confrontations d'idées c'est
normalement entre les territoires
après ce que j'ai entendu par contre ce
qu'il faut c'est que le tribunal de
commerce n'est pas supprimé non plus il
faut bien besoin son premier aussi lire
des choses parce qu'en fait on entendu
un peu tout et n'importe quoi ce qui est
sûr c'est que tous les critères
économiques
tous les critères administratifs reconnu
d'ailleurs nationalement par les
différentes institutions qui suivent
tribunaux de commerce qui suivent ces
dossiers ont classé dix ans comme étant
la ville qui pouvait le mieux accueillir
en tant que capitale régionale
ce prêt vient et spécialisés donc je
pense que c'est cohérent et que ça va
dans le bon sens pour d'ailleurs dijon
et besançon puisque les grands dossiers
seront gérés effectivement à dijon et y
avait que toutes les compétences
nécessaires il ya aussi des compétences
à besançon et je suis sûr d'ailleurs que
les uns et les autres travaillant
ensemble à eric alauzet on va c'est lui
quand même l'arrivée de benoît villo
notre cinquième invité bonjour n'a pas
de président de la cgpme de bourgogne
franche comté désormais que ça eric
alauzet donc sur les critères objectifs
vous parlez de bon sens bon sens et
référence au fond et apprennent de fonds
et imprègne de forme sur le fond ski et
se parlent de celui-ci avec le tribunal
de commerce
c'était la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase il y avait une
cohérence de répartition des directions
de l'état
3 à besançon 5 à dijon on aurait préféré
4 4 on va partir une prod compact
commente habilité d'apothicaire mais il
ya effectivement la direccte la bonne en
sous emploi formation travail et moi
j'ai plaidé je n'ai cessé de plaider
auprès du ministre l'intérieur qui ont
été tout à fait d'accord pour gagner ou
d'une logique cohérente par rapport aux
satellites de l'état aux opérateurs de
l'état
nous avons perdu pour l'emploi qui
devaient aller avec la direccte il ya eu
des débats interminables sur l'insee en
appel samedi étude de l'insee qui devait
avec la direccte et tribunal de commerce
est venu comme troisième élément qui a
fait déborder le vase
donc sur le fond si on respecte et
cohérence thématique avec chacun ses
spécificités et c'est comme ça qu'on
sera plus en franche comté
le tribunal de commerce spécialisés
devaient l'habillant sont sur le fond le
bon sens maintenant sur la forme ce qui
s'est passé était tout à fait
inacceptable
on va y venir on y reviendra parce que
ça s'est par ailleurs gardiste un
portrait des préoccupations des citoyens
que l'on soit en bourgogne et en franche
comté je pense que tous les citoyens
imagine bien que entre dijon et besançon
on puisse voyager facilement que l'on
puisse échanger par tous les moyens de
communication modernes et que je crois
que si l'on continue comme cela à se
battre en disant que intel à une telle
chose star je dis c'est pas du tout est
logique on conduit dans une logique de
grandes régions avec une capitale
régionale qui est dijon et avec bien
évidemment des complémentarités avec
jenson et pâques avec besançon nous
avons aussi des villes comme mâcon comme
chalon et comme bien d'autres où il faut
qu'on travaille tous de concert pour
faire en sorte de défendre notre
territoire dans la compétition qui
existe d'ailleurs entre les grands
région donc je pense qu'on va continuer
à faire défiler la parole si vous
déséquilibre or on va se tourner vers
dominique roy puisque les acteurs
économiques disent on t'a sont montés au
créneau sur ce sujet de
du tribunal de commerce spécialisé alors
tribunal de commerce spécialisé on a
appris à cette occasion une création à
dire qu'il n'ya pas d'emplois en jeu ça
va traiter au maximum cinq dossiers par
an est ce que finalement là il n'y a pas
de disproportion entre la réaction des
bisontins et la réalité du sujet je vais
reprendre les propos d'eric aloses et je
crois que c'est la goutte d'eau qui a
fait déborder le vase
on se situe entre besançon et dijon
depuis des années non pas dans un combat
mais dans une concurrence bien normal
entre capitales régionales et besançon a
souvent estimé sans doute à juste titre
que un certain nombre de sièges sociaux
d'entreprises privées public partait à
dijon et que l'un vers ce n'était pas
forcément vrai il y a eu un partage
équitable je crois un bon travail de
fait entre françois rebsamen et le maire
de besançon sous l'égide et du préfet et
de la présence du conseil régional
s'agissant des services de l'état et
rappelé par le député grandguillaume à
l'instant ce sur quoi nous nous sommes
élevés la mobilisation du monde
économique d'elle dès le 27 février
c'était là aussi sur la méthode puisque
votre communiqué vaut mieux et la
désinvolture au pire mieux les prix au
pire du mépris oui démo était fort mais
bon je crois que mon appel n'a pas droit
de défendre sa ville et les intérêts de
dijon mais tout autant qu en effet
jean-louis fousseret les milieux
économiques peuvent défendre la leur
monsieur chevreuil
la question n'est pas là c'est que le
président du tribunal de commerce de
besançon
pierre bourgeois nous avait annoncé lors
de la rentrée solennelle documents à
l'appui que le choix a été fait c'était
besançon le conseil national des
tribunaux de commerce
je ne pense pas qu'ils se soient
avancées en amande a remis en cause
souvent l'existence de documents
lors de la réunion du 22 février du
conseil national du tribunal de commerce
le projet de décret qu'il n'était même
pas signé de madame taubira mais
présenté par les services du nouveau
garde des sceaux monsieur urvoas décret
qui ne demandait qu'à être j'allais dire
signé et fifres et si je puis dire mais
tu es bien dit le drezen sont comme
tribunal de commerce spécialisé votre
deuxième question en effet au 2 voilà
c'est au-delà du symbole
rappelons en effet sera qu on a aussi un
rôle de pédagogie que ça ne supprime pas
aller tribunal les tribunaux de commerce
dans leur ressort actuelle mais qu'il
s'agit en effet de traiter les affaires
de plus de 250 salariés
benoît ville où vous quelle est votre
position passées alors là c'est la cgpme
25 a cosigné à le communiqué dont
parlait jérémy chevreuils et vous alors
en tant que président de la cgpme
bourgogne franche comté vous dites quoi
est ce que c'est vrai que le plus grand
nombre de grandes entreprises se
trouvent dans l'air dijonnaise ya plus
de magistrats explique à besançon est ce
que vous trouvez ça logique
moi je vais sortir du spectre guéguerre
je ne comprends pas absolument pas je
comprends pas cette polémique puisque
effectivement moi je vais parler du
point de vue économique uniquement
cantonnée aux entreprises et qu'on se
retrouve confronté à ce type de problème
c'est à dire être devant un tribunal de
commerce par qui on a envie d'être prêté
par celui qui a le plus de compétences
et d'appétence à le faire tribunal de
commerce de dijon 29 jugent 19 à
besançon 30 h 30 pour finir averses
restant incompétent tradition iv c'est
la capacité à mener de dossiers
supplémentaires le nombre de juges et à
les traiter avec une rapidité
supplémentaire parce que le nerf de la
guerre c'est la décision rendue est la
rapidité de la décision pour sauver des
emplois et rend l'entreprise attend donc
quand on se met dans spectre la dijon a
tous les arguments pour récupérer le
tribunal de commerce
derrière de quoi on parle on parle de
quatre affaires ou cinq potentiels
potentiel parents parents ça n'enlève en
rien les compétences du tribunal de
commerce de besançon qui va garder celle
qu'elle avait jusqu'à jusqu'à présent de
manière beaucoup plus
partisane parce qu'il faut le dire il
faut être partisan dépendantes en
tribunal de commerce des viandes 23 juge
sur 28 cgpme dirigé par la cgpme
tribunal de commerce de besançon un juge
sur 19 cgpme donc vous comprenez bien où
est mon parti frileux dans il est normal
forcément cola cm du doubs ne vois pas
du tout de la même ville alors je sais
pas ils sont peut-être trompés de
syndicats j'en sais rien mais en tous
les cas qu'en ce qui concerne la cgpme
bourgogne franche comté et celui là la
mission que je représente le lamih la
fonction que j'ai effectivement en étant
complètement pragmatique on peut dire
que le tribunal de commerce de dijon en
retirant toutes ces notions partizan a
toutes les capacités à plus de capacités
que celui de besançon pour l'accueillir
et je voudrais terminer par une chose
l'équilibré est ce que vous a longtemps
dû réagir nous en bourgogne en côte d'or
quand les services de la dréal de la
direccte de la laddh de est également
super rectorat sont allés à besançon non
c'est un équilibre
on n'a pas crié au sol ou en disant on
nous retire des choses qu'est ce que
c'est comment voulez vous construire une
région forte avec une dualité aussi
forte
il faut une métropole régionale forte et
c'est dijon et il faut que ce soit comme
ça sinon notre région n'a aucun sens et
ne se développera pas françois berthelon
en tant que président du comité
économique
ce conseil ne vais pas y arriver
économique social et environnemental de
bourgogne franche comté
vous avez j'imagine vous avez pris de la
hauteur sur ce dossier est ce que c'est
un scandale que le tribunal de commerce
spécialisé était récupéré par dijon je
vais vous dire très sincèrement bonne
chose
ce débat m'horripile voilà avec claire
votre frappe osée mais mais de quoi
parle-t-on
est ce que aujourd'hui la future région
cette prime une aile de commerces
spécialisés avec ses 5 d'affaires ou
est-ce que c'est véritablement la
création d'une nouvelle région
thématique de tout un tas d'autres
choses mais c'est symptomatique mais on
ya toujours eu des dissensions entre les
villes entre les régions et c est ce que
vous on pense en étant un tout petit peu
sérieux aujourd'hui que le fond du
problème c'est le tribunal de commerce
spécialisé pendant que ronald province
comment ça
c'est pendant que l'ile-de-france bostik
et ça n'a pas été une région qui a été
recomposée et que la respectivement les
faux sont envoyés nous on est en train
de se dire oh la la la la la qu'est-ce
que c'est embêtant on a alors
effectivement mais est-ce que je me
tourne vraiment sur ce que j'ai entendu
et sans mais mes chansons d esprit de ma
part est ce que il faut vraiment parler
des gouttes d'eau qui font déborder le
vase
ces chaînes ont une goutte d'eau oui ça
fait déborder un vase
mais si je ne m'abuse il n'y a guère que
la goutte d'eau qui déborde et la très
sincèrement aujourd'hui je trouve que la
mesure est con pensons à nos territoires
pensons à la bourgogne franche comté
pensons à la construction de cette
nouvelle région c'est que nous on s'est
attaché à faire au niveau du conseil
économique social environnemental de
bourgogne d'une part de franche-comté
d'autre part et dans le nouveau conseil
qui sait qu'ils appellent l'ensemble des
2 on s'est mis à bosser en sang sans se
dire qu'il y avait des prérogatives de
l'un de l'autre
il y en a toujours des prérogatives oui
mais soyons sérieux quand même que
peuvent penser les gens de du territoire
de belfort ou de montbéliard du creusot
montchanin de c2c guerre mais qui ne
ressemble à rien durée des mots pour le
définir
encore une fois je pense que et là je
vous rejoins tout à fait sauter odier de
thaler sur la forme c'est absolument
davantage ce qui a été fait on n'aurait
jamais dû faire des choses pareilles
c'est lamentable ont ainsi prochainement
sur quelque chose et c'est dommage vous
parliez de la forme américaine a
effectivement offert au nahd challenge
énorme devant nous l'enjeu de cette
grande région avec deux anciennes
capitales régionales c'est pas autour
d'une métropole que les choses vont se
jouer parce que dijon par rapport à
strasbourg par rapport à lyon et paris
reconnaissant le ça restera une petite
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ya pas de
métropole en juin je comptais enregistré
au lac métropolitain avec les deux
anciennes capitales régionales
c'est ça la force de cette région et la
nécessité absolue de cette région si on
veut avec les territoires qui sont
autour ruraux et des villes moyennes
réussir cette région il ya eu trois
défauts dans cette affaire-là
le premier c'est l' équilibre
quand j'entends les uns et les autres
dire il avait plus de
le maire a dit jose cadence en mai alors
prenons les dossiers les uns après les
autres
il doit tout va se terminer à dijon
c'est le contraire de ce qu'il faut
faire le contraire de ce qu'il faut
faire ce qui a été affirmé mais hier et
musulmans non décidément les quidams où
se joue avec les directions d'état il se
jouera et je sais la présidente de
région très attentive à cette affaire-là
ya une cohérence des directions du
conseil régional avec les directions de
l'état et que les opérateurs de l'état
pour l'emploi devait être à deux ans en
arrêt cardiaque par une force autour de
ces thématiques non la question
d'équilibré et les majeures la deuxième
chose c'est l'engagement l'engagement il
ya eu débat sur effectivement dijon
besançon c'est pas la sphère du siècle
du tribunal de commerce
j'ai mis un débat au départ mais le 26
novembre et du 26 novembre au 22 février
pendant trois mois
c'était besançon sur le décret qui était
près quatre jours avant c'était deux ans
sont sur la forme c'est tout à fait
inacceptable ce qui est c'est à dire
c'est que s'est il passé dans ces quatre
jours à l'asse tout ce qui s'est passé
bien où tout le monde le sait très le
sait bien c'est que y'a eu l'affluence
du premier magistrat de cette ville qui
a fait tourner le boulet spéciale non
non parce que ça remet en cause la
cohérence ça parce que demain si on dit
que pôle emploi est et pôle emploi est
ici à dijon
si le tribunal de commerce établit gens
si le bureau de l'insee sont à dijon
mais qu'est ce que fait la direccte à
besançon il dira à défaut la ramener à
besançon donc faut vraiment garder cette
cette cohérence entre les différents
services est très très important le
royaume et la diabolique que vous avez
je pense que vous avez tort vous avez
tort de parler d' influence parce que si
c'était le cas ça voudrait dire en fait
que vous n'avez aucune influence pour
détourner dossier donc en tête pour en
fait vous êtes en train de vous tirer
des balles dans le pied
et à force de manquer deux balles de jeu
manqué deux balles dans le pied donc il
faut que je pense qu'il faut arrêter
donc c'est pas à mon avis comme ça qu'il
faut traiter les choses
aujourd'hui ce soit était fait et en
toute conscience est sur de bons
arguments
dans le même temps il y à une capitale
régionale aujourd'hui la grande région
bourgogne franche comté
selligent n'en déplaise à ceux qui qui
comptait ce sommet c'est une réalité
maintenant la question c'est comment on
favorise un écosystème qui soit
favorable à nos entreprises à l'emploi
dans notre territoire pour faire en
sorte de pouvoir justement croître de
pouvoir accueillir de nouvelles
entreprises et ce n'est pas ni dijon ni
la mairie ni qui comptent qui va décider
d'où s'implante une entreprise
l'entreprise s'implante par rapport aux
conditions d'accueil qui lui sont
proposés par rapport à elle au gisti qui
lui proposait par rapport à différents
éléments au bassin d'emploi par rapport
à la main d'oeuvre qu'est disponible ce
sont les vraies questions qu'il faut
traiter
or aujourd'hui moi qu'est ce que je vois
je vois des salariés qui vivent à dijon
et qui travaille à besançon où qu'ils
vivent à besançon qui travaillent à
dijon des étudiants qui font tous les
jours on entend ça vous comprenez qu'à
besançon mais attendait beaucoup du
ramené beaucoup d'élus ont leur nom la
ville est déposée par la voisine disait
régulièrement je vais régulièrement à
besançon dans ma famille qui aime bien
châtie bien
régulièrement on comment dire on peut se
critiquer et c'est sûr voilà le foot ou
sur autre chose
certains d'autres domaines bon c'est
normal voilà donc qui aime bien châtie
bien
c'est logique entre dijon et besançon ya
toujours eu cette histoire d'ailleurs
pas à l'époque de monsieur fint et de
monsieur poujade il y avait déjà des
débats et moi je me rappelle quand
j'étais enfant il y avait même pas de
panneau pour indiquer dix jours quand
j'étais à besançon bon c'est comme ça
c'était l'époque du pont de tout on a
évolué vire les choses évoluent mais à
l'heure où on parle de dématérialisation
à l'heure où on parle de digitalisation
à l'heure où on parle des six séances
des services publics ont ce qu'il faut
c'est faire en sorte surtout de pouvoir
permettre et bien à nos concitoyens aux
entreprises d'avoir le meilleur service
proposé au niveau de cette grande région
et il ya la place pour tout le monde il
ya la place pour besançon comme pour
disons comme pour toutes les autres
villes est d'ailleurs notre grande
région ne se résume pas uniquement à
dijon et besançon
je viens il ya quand même
les territoires ruraux périurbains et
d'autres civils qu'il faut dépasser ce
sujet clivant et pour avoir plus
d'autres expressions même urticants
entre nos deux villes
raison pour laquelle je rappelle
contexte historique de cette concurrence
entre les villes
vous affirmez que dijon et la capitale
régionale
je crois que la décision elle sera prise
au mois de juin je crois par le conseil
régional c'est la capitale
administratrice pour l'instant diana
frais en dérision le chef-lieu c'est à
dire le siège de la préfecture de région
et la loi indique que le siège du
conseil régional ne peut pas être au
même lieu que la préfecture de région ce
kof saut en effet sauf majorité des
trois cinquièmes aux régionales et c'est
là que je voudrais en venir s'agissant
du choix de cette future capitale
là aussi pour reprendre le lait ce que
disait benoît tout à l'heure quel est
l'intérêt c'est celui qu'on représente
benoît dans l'interpro et et moi la
chambre de commerce avec mon homologue
ri si xavier mir poids quel est le
besoin des entreprises dans ces
affaires-là on nous a vendu la fusion
des régions dans un premier temps mais
ça n'a pas duré très longtemps comme
étant une source d'économie pour très
vite dire non ce sont des régions qui
seront fortes dans un contexte européen
et qui permettront de lever notamment
des fonds feder pour être plus fort
ensemble exister et justement avoir un
retour pur pour nos entreprises si l'on
prend ce parti pris alors la capitale de
cette grande région voient elles-mêmes
être forte
il faut dépasser le clivage deux ans on
dijon et je crois que eric commencé à en
parler tout à l'heure avec ceux de ce
pôle métropolitain jeudi que nous avons
toute notre place
les milieux économiques dans le débat
qui doit avoir lieu
s'agissant de qui sera là la capitale
régionale est à mon sens en ayant deux
obsessions
la première c'est de dire qu'est ce que
doit être une capitale régionale d'une
grande région
moi je pense qu'il ya deux éléments
d'une part c'est une gouvernance à
l'intérieur même de cette région et
d'autre part par rapport au jeu là les
très très très court et par rapport à
l'extérieur
l'extérieur c'est de démontrer que l'une
ou l'autre ou les deux dans ce pôle
métropolitain sont attractives au niveau
national et européen
quant à l'intérieur le rôle d'une
capitale régionale d'une grande région
comme la bourgogne franche comté doit
être c'est une préoccupation que nous
avons eues au conseil économique social
et environnemental de bourgogne et de
franche comté c'est de dire il faut
adapter ou un nouveau des nouveaux modes
de gouvernance c'est-à-dire qu'en effet
le débat s'est pas besançon ou dijon que
ce soit l'une que ce soit l'autre allait
dire dieu reconnaîtra les siens c'est
une chose mais surtout la capacité de
l'union de l'une ou de l'autre à faire
vivre les territoires trop souvent
jeunes est très également demandé à
lever le siège des concerts hivernale
soit besançon c'est un message
compensation ne vient pas aujourd'hui
pour dire c'est besançon et dijon jeudi
précisons quel est le rôle d'une
capitale régionale dans le concert des
grandes régions des deux méthodes jeudi
que les milieux économiques ont toute
leur part dans cette affaire l'a eu
égard à la dimension intérieure
extérieure que le débat c'est de faire
vivre l'ensemble du territoire et que
peut-être nos ex capitale régionale dans
le périmètre qui était le leur non
peut-être pas toujours suffisamment fait
rempli leur rôle de capitale régionale
c'est à dire de prendre en compte
l'ensemble des territoires d'être des
animateurs des corps de la tête de ce
qui se passe sur les territoires
françois berthelon alors vous vous
présidez le le ceser de la grande région
maintenant et vous vous êtes saisis de
ces questions de ti libre a déjà la
première chose et je m'en excuse auprès
de lui mais je voudrais reprendre un des
points que disait dominique roy et
quelques instants effectivement la
capitale régionale c'est à dire le siège
du de la future région sera défini sera
proposé sera proposée par l'assemblée
nouvelle vient du
à la hauteur de 3,5 des trois cinquièmes
mais ce n'est pas une décision
définitive qui est prise à ce moment là
la décision définitive elle est prise
par le conseil d'état faut pas oublier
ça c'est le conseil d'état qui en
dernier lieu à l'étang de en dernier
ressort
donc ça c'est comme apprendre à l'idée
la décision du conseil régional écoutez
là vous verrez je savais pas que j'étais
au conseil d'état n'a en fait jamais en
paix n'est cité mais sincèrement je bien
évidemment ça va peser bien sûr mais je
pense qu'il faut respecter la décision
qui sera prise et c'est la liberté au
plus haut niveau des taxes à françois
berthelon se pose la même question qu'à
dominique roy est ce que vous souhaitez
ou souhaitez-vous que le siège du
conseil régional soit implanté alors je
veux dire très sincèrement la question
est extrêmement complexe je pense qu une
région forte doit avoir une capitale
forte comme si le unit alors mais ce qui
veut dire par exemple en ce qui concerne
je prends le cas de l'auvergne
rhône-alpes
j'ai la certitude que clermont va
profiter de la force de ronald et de et
de lyon ça paraît assez évident on je
veux bien qu'on parle aujourd'hui de la
force de l'auvergne d'antan je pense que
lou verne va gagner de sa proximité
espèce de la force de la région rhône
alpes alors aujourd'hui je le pense que
dire qu'il faut que la capitale soit
dans l'une des deux villes je dirais
sincèrement que ce n'est pas à moi d'y
répondre
je dis simplement ce genre là pour je
serais d'accord avec mon homologue de
franche comté
je pense qu'il faut faire un petit un
équilibre sur les forces et les
puissances de chacune des deux villes
d'une part et puis d'autre part arrivé à
1 ne pas se bloquer sur la partie
géographique
vous parliez tout à l'heure de métropole
savez est quelque chose qui avait été
longuement défini par la ministre ce que
j'ai j'ai eu à le défendre au niveau
national avec madame lebranchu où il
était question d'une métropole
ce qui a rejoint niais dijon besançon
avec dolomieu bien évidemment quelle est
la meilleure solution aujourd'hui
moi personnellement c'est vrai que c'est
une interrogation forte que j'ai je dis
très sincèrement je penserai étant
peut-être bourguignon que vont peut-être
d'un côté ou de l'autre mais j'essaye
d'être saoul et honnête avec moi-même et
sincèrement je n'ai pas les moyens de
trancher aujourd'hui donc je ne le ferai
pas laurent grandguillaume ça vous
paraît très cohérent en terme
d'aménagement du territoire de placer le
siège du conseil régional à besançon
puisque la préfecture de région et à
dire moi je pense que le conseil
régional il peut très bien avoir le
siège à lyon et en même temps avoir des
services qui travaillent dans les deux
villes vers ya pas deux en fait en fait
ce qui me gêne en fait non ces débats
c'est qu'on ne raisonne jamais en termes
d'efficience en termes de services au
public
en fait on raisonne en termes de
localisation mais en fait venir entre
digoin de jean songez que comprendre
qu'elle n'est pas quand même dix heures
de route pour se rendre d'une ville à
l'autre
il me semble qu'on a des moyens de
communication comme à s'avancer au 21ème
siècle
je crois que ce qu'il faut surtout une
vocation symbolique de tel ou tel
service il ya des emplois car il ya des
emplois mais en fait il ya beaucoup de
familles aussi qui travaille dans une
ville ou dans l'autre mais qui ne vivent
pas forcément dans une île aujourd'hui
l'air urbaine en fait de dijon comme de
deux ans on on va dire il ya des points
de comment dire de complémentarité il ya
des personnes qui vivent à 20 km de
dijon jean connaît mais qui travaille à
besançon chaque jour et qui prennent
leur voiture chaque jour donc bon
sortons de ces débats en dvi anciens qui
n'ont pas lieu d'être
il y aura des choix à faire faisons les
bons choix je pense qu'effectivement
dijon c'est la capitale régionale de
cette grande région bourgogne franche
comté les crampons vestiaire qu'il faut
construire un réseau métropolitain dijon
besançon et qu'il faut faire en sorte
avec françois rebsamen avec jean louis
fousseret justement de porter de manière
commune la force d'autres régions aussi
pour qu'elle pèse owni médecin de 30 ans
souhaiterait mettre notre région est
petite par rapport à d'autres régions
sur le poids économique en particulier
donc si on se divise
cela profitera à ceux qui veulent régner
pour nous qui venons à vélo j'aurais
reprendre le terme de l'emploi l'emploi
je penserai effectivement dans un
premier temps on s'était dit qu'on
allait mutualiser donc les craintes qui
a été considérable en disant on va
perdre des emplois on sent contenu d'une
chose aujourd'hui on les agents y aura
toujours autant glissé y aura toujours
autant d'intérêt de ceux de transport
etc
donc les emplois simplement
effectivement il ya peut-être un petit
peu de délocalisation sur teodosic par
exemple sur le nombre de fonctionnaires
d'état en région ce sera moins 20% sur
la grande région d'ici 2020 donc les
deux villes vont perdre un peu ils
conduisent en réalité si jamais il y
avait pas eu fusion est ce que vous
pensez que ça aurait été très différent
je pense que la fusion a été bon je vais
pas dire le prétexte parce que cela
sous-entendrait qui est une manipulation
derrière
non moi je dis que les cas un phénomène
normal éventuellement qui bon qu'on peut
accepter ou regretter mais je pense
qu'on s'inscrit dans une logique
je ne crois pas que cette fusion
précisément et là que je suis totalement
d'accord
est ce que disait laurent grandguillaume
tout de suite on n'a pas détruit
d'emplois pour le moment il ya une
inquiétude des ddd des salariés c'est
vrai et on la comprend et je pense que
pour leveaux n'a pas suffisamment fait
pédagogie l' auto pour répondre à
l'inquiétude des personnels mais pour le
moment on essaye de préserver au maximum
et là mon avis c'est encore une fois un
mauvais débat de dire que la fusion des
régions va déséquilibrer un côté ou
l'autre à mon avis a pas d équipe on n'a
rien préparé
justement cette fusion des régions on
aboutisse à une fracturation
territoriale par des débats comme on a
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il facture que
l'on puisse aller de l'avant ensemble
notre pour notre région pour ses
habitants
la porte est maintenant les emplois et
pour nos entreprises nos tpe nos pme
nous dit je vais pour moi là encore une
fois le débat géographique il a pas lieu
d'être et le débat je le mets là où j'ai
nommé la part des guerres de territoire
et
uniquement de clocher c'est complètement
ubuesque la capitale de la région ça
doit être celle qui a le plus de
capacité à emmener cette région en tant
qu'image en tant que nouvelle marque en
tant que force économique et drainer
l'ensemble du territoire derrière une
dynamique économique
en ce qui nous concerne sorte laquelle s
bat prenons les chiffres et regardons
des deux villes laquelle a le plus de
capacité à emmener la région et l'image
de la nouvelle grande région bourgogne
franche comté qui bénéficiera et qui
fera là bénéficié au reste de la grande
région de toute cette dynamique et cette
image alors après les services qu'il
soit basé à besançon et dijon on peut
avoir un équilibre le souligner laurent
tout à l'heure à voir des déséquilibres
dans dit dans les deux villes ce qui est
déjà le cas
je comprends pas puisque c'est déjà le
cas on a une présidente de région qui
est franc comtoise on à son cabinet qui
est déjà installée à besançon
on a aujourd'hui la dréal comme je le
disais tout à l'heure la direccte on a
le super rectorat à besançon l'equilibre
pour l'instant il est parfaitement
respectée pour moi et on n'a pas entendu
encore une fois de réaction de notre
part en criant au loup quand on enlevait
des services à dijon pour les mettre à
besançon c'est là où je ne comprends pas
cette polémique stérile quand nous
regardons les chiffres donnés par la crc
la crc i qui nous donne des chiffres sur
le poids économique des différents
départements et des différentes villes
la regardons les attentivement et
regardons ce que pèse la côte d'or par
rapport aux doux
regardons ce que pèse un poids
économique alors peut-être il faut y
avoir une capitale régionale économique
et d'autres capitale administrative
ailleurs je n'en sais rien mais en tous
les cas pour que ça fonctionne il faut
une unité derrière un projet commun et
derrière une figure de proue qui sera
cette métropole décidé autour de dijon
besançon et une communauté mais vous
alliez vous aviez tout à l'heure j'ai
donné de dijon puisque dijon en
métropole et dans cette nouvelle grande
région besançon communauté urbaine c'est
ça les nouvelles choses que va apporter
la région et donc c'est dijon bien tenu
mais une métropole à terme même si c'est
une petite métropole au regard
aujourd'hui et d'autres métropoles mais
il ya 157 me l'a dit l'habitant à dijon
il y en a cent dix sept mille
aujourd'hui à besançon
l'agglo ces deux sens
deux cent mille à dijon on à 250 milles
on a les moyens de faire évoluer tout
cela en rendant le territoire attractif
nous ce qu'on souhaite entreprendre
entreprises entreprises de bourgogne
franche comté c'est que nos territoires
sont attractifs qu'il soit identifié par
une grande capitale pour qu'il donne
envie de manière exogènes à des
entreprises de venir sur le territoire
c'est le seul intérêt c'est qu'on crée
de l'emploi par une grosse région forte
avec une figure de proue forte où tout
le monde soit derrière avec un équilibre
évidemment des bénéfices que cette
grande capitale va apporter à la région
et vous proposeront bouillir et rigal
osé depuis plusieurs vies n'est pas ce
qu'il donnait la parole parce que déjà
nous sommes deux pour représenter la
france comptait sur trois et c'est papa
il n'y a pas de chaque région puis
quelqu'un qui sera le juge de paix qui
serait le président qui serait le
président de la conel franche comté de
bourgogne et de la dijonnaise
moi j'ai envie qu'on fasse des choses
avec dijon n'oublions pas qu'il est long
jeunesse que derrière tous les l'enjeu
est ce qu'il ya une espèce de complexe
d'infériorité finalement déduire
je pense qu'on a besoin d'une confiance
un peu quand même mais vous savez sur
tous les territoires c'est ce qui se
passe malheureusement depuis la nuit des
temps dans ce pays extrêmement
centralisateur la france tout est à
paris et le désert français il faut pas
qu'on reproduise ça et quand on cite
l'exemple de lyon et clermont ferrand
c'est justement le mauvais exemple parce
qu'il nous concerne pour cette région
une grande région rhône alpes est qu'une
grande capitale régionale
et évidemment on voit bien comment des
choses se cristallisent autour de autour
de dijon c'est très différent ici ces
deux petites régions avec deux petites
capitales donc il faut parier sur le
binôme
sinon on ne va pas réussir c'est ça
notre atout commun et c'est ça qu'il
faut viser ensemble rang a dit tout à
l'heure
beaucoup de choses très justes en dix
ans le monde changeait que l'avant
d'ambition une nouvelle gouvernance et
qu'effectivement et tout ce que tu as
dit en fait pu amener les conclusions
assez radicalement opposées et est
différent voilà donc moi je pense que
effectivement pour parier sur c'est sur
ces deux villes en plus elles sont très
proches très très moche elle seule car
en france on a aussi d'aussi près aussi
deux capitales régionales aussi proches
l'une de l'autre
donc on peut très bien avoir des
positionnements halde en une capitale et
dans l'une et dans l'autre pour être
efficace regardez on va ce qu'est ce qui
était gênant dans cette affaire là c'est
qu'on prend les dossiers les uns après
les autres
l'esprit retrouvons l'esprit de la
réforme un partage un équilibre 3,5
c'est pas 4 4 c'est pas grave et
continue dans cet esprit-là or on l'a
perdue le naturel
chassez le naturel il revient au galop
après on prend les dossiers les uns
après les autres
il ya chaque dossier dire par là c'est
du rapide à ces dix jours bien non
regardez il ya d'autres arbitrages à
venir
il ya loin def il ya l'onema
il ya le coup le cross etc
eh bien il va falloir met tout sur la
table messieurs en même temps pas des
dossiers les uns après les autres et on
regarde globalement ces immenses
première et alençon le siège du conseil
de l'environnement la dréal et à
besançon il est logique que louer n'être
que le débat soit à besançon et en
franche comté
en revanche il sera tout à fait logique
il est logique avec la draf
l'agriculture la forêt qui est à dijon
qui est la chambre d'agriculture
d'ailleurs là ses filles auraient dû
être à besançon par doro c'est le
mexique moi c'est pas du tout celle de
nos villes
on adore on a des forces qui sont
historiques qui sont le résultat de la
tradition il faut valoriser fort cela et
il faut les consolider dans chacune de
nos deux de nos deux capitales
régionales et je pense qu'effectivement
vu la proximité de nos deux régions de
nous deux anciennes capitales régionales
il n'est pas impossible que le chef lieu
pour répondre à votre question jérémy
chevreuil que le chef lieu se trouve à
dijon et que le siège de la région du
conseil régional se trouve a besoin
cette proximité c'est tout à fait
possible ici qu'il serait pas possible
dans une autre région
regardons la spécificité de noter vous
est favorable à cet arbitrage là ou pas
je pense que ça ça se tient
ça se tient tout ça tout ça n'est pas
antinomique on peut avoir une capitale
régionale à dijon et massifier les pôles
de compétences économiques autour des
régions qui ont plus d'atouts
on parle de besançon avec ses atouts
économiques et d'autres à tout n'a pas
dit long
ma session les services autour de ses
atouts économiques autour de bennoo son
corps ça c'est du pragmatisme dit l'on
doit emmener de manière générale parce
que effectivement c'est mon avis elle a
de manière macroéconomiques
de manière générale je parle encore une
fois un peu plus d'atouts que besançon
en terme économique de nombre
d'entreprises de poids de l'économie
dans la nouvelle grande région mais si
demain le pôle industriel qui est plus
présent en franche comté et le pôle
d'excellence industrielle et est encore
dans les chiffres on mesure mais en tous
les cas il ya un fort pôle avec peugeot
autour d'eux autour de ce soir
montbéliard sochaux pour mettons les
services qui vont pouvoir représenter la
région sur ce type d'activités autour de
besançon que pour ça c'est pas c'est pas
le débat le pôle emploi pourquoi il ya
plus de chômeurs en franche-comté cas
parce que parfois formation alors qu'on
aurait dû garde à vue on disait comptoir
antoine lima fois mais on ne dit jamais
on le dit toujours mais justement
aujourd'hui personne ne demande à
quiconque de se rendre et d'être en
quelque sorte exclu que je ne sais
quelle répartition de pouvoir ou de
siège administratif
aujourd'hui c'était justifié pour jouer
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya une sorte
de combat comme si on était dans des
influences qui failli se battre pour
récupérer tel cgc
aujourd'hui c'est quoi les vrais sujets
de l'est sujet c'est comment on fait en
sorte que notre territoire commun voilà
ils puissent agir de concert pour
attirer les entreprises créent des
emplois
ça c'est la première préoccupation des
françaises et des français c'est la
première préoccupation des citoyens et
de chacun au terriroire donc c'est tous
les maires elle pas que les du coaching
compétition forcé aujourd'hui
l'entreprise s'installe par rapport à
des critères objectifs et sa salle pas
parce que le maire il va être sympa ou
parce que le président d'une
agglomération va être accueillants elle
s'installe parce que il valoir un bassin
d'emploi parce qu'il ya des personnes
qui - de former parce que elle va
regarder les taux d'imposition locaux
parce que bon on est plein de critères
donc c'est ce qu'il faut c'est
travailler sur des projets communs
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'on fait
des comptes d'apothicaire pour se dire
voilà ceci ou cela le hic si on prend
l'exemple du tribunal de commerce
spécialisé on pourra échanger pendant d
jours et des jours sur les critères
objectifs il ya beaucoup de critères
quand même qui font que c'est bien que
ce soit disons et s'est pas enlevé à
besançon quoi que ce soit on enlèverait
à besançon ensemble c est ce que est ce
qu on a mesuré ce qu'il traitait comme
fr spécialisé jusque-là besançon c'était
quasiment nul donc aujourd'hui on enlève
rien à besançon mais ces quatre affaires
par un maximum de pouvoirs et ses quatre
adversaires mais très franchement est-ce
que c'est quand même véritable ça qu'il
a fait parce que ce que disait tout à
l'heure monsieur alauzet je le rejoins
complètement
il s'agit pas de faire des additions les
unes à côté des autres
il faut avoir un projet global un projet
qui permette de dire voilà où ces coûts
sera l'efficience moi ce que je pourrais
vous dire c'est que dominique roy a
quelque chose de particulier en dehors
d'être né à dijon ce qui quand même est
une excellente chose mais dominique roy
par la même occasion il est président de
la cci du doubs et il est vice-président
délégué au ceser donc on a bossé
ensemble
est ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est
que on a fait travailler nos gens les
uns avec les autres on a train on a de
l'eau dont du rappel le conseil
économique et la deuxième assemblée de
la région à côté du conseil régional qui
est composé de chefs d'entreprises de
salariés de représentants des syndicats
du monde est monde associatif
on a fait bosser tous ces gens là
ensemble on a bossé avec eux bien
évidemment et on s'est rendu alors
termine on s'est rendu compte au début
de ce coin c'est c'était difficile et il
y avait effectivement je dirais
peut-être un petit peu de défiance
peut-être des uns par rapport aux autres
est un petit peu d'inquiétude pour ne
pas dire plus d'un peu d'inquiétude des
francs comtois par rapport aux
bourguignons mais tout cela on se rend
compte d'une chose c'est que cette
inquiétude cette réserve
elle est en train de fondre elle
disparaît pourquoi parce qu'on travaille
sur des vrais projets pourquoi parce que
on ne pense pas en terme d'opposition
dont ils omis de se dire moi je vais
avoir ce truc là plutôt que l'autre qui
n'aura pas et qui du coup me permettra
d'avoir des biscotos plus gros mais bon
sang mais mais sortons de cette de ce
débat que je trouve mes dames à la
limite je le dis sincèrement à la limite
du ridicule
dominique roy finalement on n'a pas de
sens et représenter les deux régions la
place aujourd'hui et vous le dit tous
les deux régions est-ce que besançon de
la choquer mais les francs comtois sens
pas du tout dans cet état d'esprit après
ce qui vient de se passer
ce sera là le commerçant nous avons
depuis de la grille est choquée expliqué
parce qu'on n'a pas aligné faudra qu'il
suffit d'un courrier d'un maire absent
d'une grande ville qui est proche du
président de la république pour changer
le destin commun on y rue neuve et ça
comme un ca peux pas me déranger
compreniez peut-être même des simples
citoyens au ceser
est ce que vous pensez qu'on pense comme
ça moi je le dis simplement on est
représentatif aussi bon le maire de
dijon le maire de besançon sont des gens
que je respecte énormément
nous on est des chefs d'entreprises des
représentants des syndicats
il ya des salariés et d'un nouveau boss
intelligemment ensemble avec respect ça
veut dire qu'ils avaient longtemps les
élus ne font pas les élus politiques non
membres en entendant temps les noms
d'oiseaux dont en ce moment alors ans
que je pense aussi que l'alerté pour les
initiés pour tribunal de commerce a
alerté les initiés regarder la
manifestation qui a eu 50 personnes je
pense que les la population du doubs est
loin de ces considérations du tribunal
de commerce qui ne représentent rien et
qui est ridicule je rejoins jeu je vais
maintien pour vivre à besançon qu'il ya
quand même en franche-comté un sentiment
général mais pas sur ce peut-être à
courir mais effectivement c'est
symptomatique d'autres choses sérieuses
faut que n'ont pas forcément besoin
les élus guise hohneck lions qui était
derrière cela mais je vous ferai très
honnêtement après justifié ou pas je ne
le sais pas mais le sentiment général
est réel effet non mais pas franchement
été arrêté avec sa s'épanche pas c'est
pas ou pas dire qu'il ait réussi jeune
et il ya des choix qui sont faits
dominique son objectif après moi aussi
je vais régulièrement franche comté
j'entends pas tout à fait les mêmes
choses on s'attend pas des francs
comtois qui isole à dijon va nous manger
on est foutu enfin non mais il faut
arrêter
franchement aujourd'hui ce que disent
les citoyens soient c'est surtout pour
sont confrontés au chômage qui sont
confrontés à des difficultés sociales
qui sont confrontées dont ils appellent
ils attendent des solutions
ils attendent pas en fait qu'on ait des
débats pendant des jours et des jours
pour savoir si on a un tribunal de
commerce spécialisé à tel ou tel endroit
ou tel service administratif à tel
endroit ou même d'ailleurs la plupart
n'iront jamais parce qu'en fait ce sont
parfois des services l entrée sur
publics qui travaille pour procurer des
services bien sûr mais qui ne sont pas
forcément toujours utilisé dominique roy
au delà de la sphère spécialisés voilà
ce dos et a marqué les esprits s qui a
été on va pas tourner en rond
toute la matinée là dessus c'est la
méthode la méthode pourquoi parce que
des choses visiblement engagé annoncé
d'un trait de plume les choses sont
modifiées est votre auto flageller
finale mais moi je ne cherche même pas
dans j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure au delà
de la localisation
qu'attend-t-on d'une capitale régionale
1 de l'attractivité benoît raison donc
faisons-le état des lieux des potentiel
d'attractivité de l'une et de l'autre
assez dans la méthode et le deuxième
c'est la faculté à faire vivre
l'ensemble du territoire
nous sommes trop égocentré besançon
dijon et jeu ça je crois que nous payons
le prix
dan est justement de certaine arrogance
dijonnaise par rapport au reste de la
bourgogne et idem devant son par rapport
à la franche comté on al'occasion la de
remettre au centre de la discussion
justement le rôle que doit être une
capitale
régionales au delà de l'attractivité
savoir comment faire vivre les
territoires et moi c'est la raison et
moi c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense que ce débat il faut que
l'ensemble des partenaires notamment et
économique puisse la voir mais de
manière là aussi constructif que deux
sous l'égide de la présidente du conseil
régional qui mènent quand même un
produit régional et avec le maire de
dijon et le maire de besoins dominique
roy le bowling a choisi la carte attend
des excuses moi le monde économique n'a
pas attendu la mention d'une option pour
qu'il y ait un mouvement de besançon
verdillon beaucoup de banques ces
dernières années ont déplacé leur siège
régional vers dijon l2 a été le cas
d'air sf notamment c'est donc bien qu'il
y a une attractivité supérieure à 10
amoureusement de votre raisonnement
territoriale ne ne convient pas est ce
que par exemple quand on va à la havane
et qu'on parle avec les habitants et qui
disent voilà il ya tel équipement qui
effet structurant dans l'agglomération
et qu'on va payer par exemple un peu
plus d'impôts parce que il faut financer
cet équipement est qu'on n'en a pas
forcément un accès direct
est ce que vous croyez que donc on va
rentrer dans un raisonnement ou proposer
tous les territoires
ce qu'il faut c'est mettre de la
cohérence à tout ça c'est pas de dire
que a31 à côté de besançon
des habitants qui vont dire les
bisontins vont être arrogant par rapport
à nous sommes juste à côté giron n'en
finit pas qu'après vous avez ceux qui
sont trente kilomètres de ceux qui sont
à dix kilomètres ont fini comment dans
cette liste ne règle aucun problème
en fait une fois qu'on vous entendu
parler de cette arrogance territoriale
de cette opposition entre les communes
quelles sont les solutions
quelles sont les solutions ou leur dis
juste que nous sommes en capacité de
proposer pour les habitants justement
alors quels sont les groupes présents il
ya possibilité de coopérer est ce que
c'est insurmontable déjà regarder ce qui
se passe pour la santé ou pour
l'université je trouve ça assez
exemplaire ce qui se passe entre nos
deux cas c'est la régionale depuis
quelques années et on sait qu'à
l'échelle nationale face à lyon face à
strasbourg nos hôpitaux de dijon et de
l'eau chu de dijon et de besançon ne
s'en sortiront que s'il se partagent un
certain nombre de spécialisation la
chirurgie cardiaque à dijon par exemple
pour avoir un niveau de compétences
extrêmement élevé je suis en gironde
à besançon voilà et c'est ce chemin là
que tu aussi c'est sur ce chemin là qui
avaient présidé à l'organisation des
grandes régions
sachez le c'est toujours plus difficile
et vous savez pour la plus petite des
deux comparses de région de ville
d'autres territoires
c'est toujours plus risqués nous avons
pris ces risques là et nous avons eu
confiance en franche-comté
particulièrement puisque là dans
d'autres régions où il ya eu beaucoup
plus de réticence nous avons joué le jeu
donc continuons ce jour ce jeu-là
retrouvons l'esprit qui a présidé à la
répartition des grandes directions
d'état ce que vous avez dit monsieur
viléo tout à l'heure il va tout à fait
dans le sens de ce que je souhaite
également assurons nos pôles nos pôles
de force dans chacune des deux capitales
pour créer ce pôle métropolitain qui
sera notre force qui sera notre notre
spécifité encore appliqué une
coopération à ma connaissance et d'une
des seules en 2008 il y a eu une
convention signée entre les deux
agglomérations
à propos du tramway pour l'ingénierie
financière par exemple pour regrouper
tout ça est ce que le vice président aux
finances du grand dijon
donc je m'occupe et en particulier du
financement du tramway j'étais allé à
besançon rencontré mon collègue est
également président des finances et nous
avions travaillé ensemble pour échanger
sur les expériences sur commande à les
financer ces équipements donc oui ça
existe déjà depuis un moment mais
évidemment heureusement d'ailleurs c'est
vraiment très bon ballon les tramways
que pour dijon comme pour vos enfants ce
sont des équipements très important qui
d'ailleurs on crée aussi des emplois qui
ont créé de l'investissement et et on
n'a eu aucun souci à travailler ensemble
de concert pour échanger sur nos écrans
et ses taxes métropolitan dont vous
parlez tous qu'est-ce que ça harvey
exactement parce que ça parle pas
forcément aux gens qui nous regardent
c'est quoi un axe mais déjà un réseau
métropolitain depuis les années 2000 je
crois début 2000 c'est pas très concret
sa fille mais si on ne voit pas les
faits quelles sont les questions
concrètes qui percute
aujourd'hui les citoyens les questions
de transport le prénom la défense des
transports voilà on y est sous une
question des transports trajets domicile
travail
voilà comment on peut travailler
ensemble sur question combien de
personnes sont concernées par ces
trajets domicile travail
combien d'étudiants
eh bien vous entre besançon et dijon
tout pour étudier sur la bonne en soi
disant et voilà il y en a puisque à
différentes spécialités
donc si ces éléments il faut prendre en
compte et comment on peut travailler sur
ces questions concrètes qui relève de
nos compétences comment on peut avancer
sur ces sujets je pense que ce sera
d'optimiser les fortes cette nouvelle
grande région en arrêtant d'avoir le
sentiment d'être bourguignon francs
grand poème est d'avoir le sentiment
aujourd'hui de bourgogne franche comté
et d'optimiser prendre les forces en
présence
quelles sont les forces du doubs de la
franche-comté quelles sont les forces de
la bourgogne et d'optimiser autour de
sai de construire cette région tant d'un
point de vue économique
moi je ne ferai pas de l'analyse sur ce
qui me concerne pas mais autour de ces
pôles forts qui vont représenter notre
grande région on va optimiser et on va
mutualiser et on va rationaliser et on
va avoir une communication plus forte
vis-à-vis des entreprises et du monde
économique extérieure de me croire je
reprends les propos de benoît où il
force force tu as raison et quels sont
les complémentarités qui sont justement
de nature a organisé par le jeu des
acteurs économiques ces complémentarités
et un véritable projet homogène je
prends par exemple ce que nous faisons
au niveau que je suis là au pied de la
chambre de commerce du doubs ce que nous
avons engagé avec la chambre de commerce
du 21 finalement c'est la fusion des
régions qui nous a amenés à travailler
davantage ensemble ont servi que le
réseau est un peu malmené par l'état
donc on est dans des recherches de
mutualisation de synergies cette voie là
cette fusion a été l'occasion pour nous
alors qu'on se connaissait même pas avec
xavier à mirepoix le président de la
ccit 21 ignorait bien sûr mais bien sûr
mais bien sûr de mettre en place des
chantiers de mutualisation important
pour l'économie en matière de formation
nous sommes complémentaires parce que
nous n'assumons pas dans l'aisne cadre
juridique mais également sur les publics
les mêmes formations en matière de
tourisme
on le dit dans le rapprochement on l'a
dit avec françois dans le golan en effet
plus qu'un conseil économique et social
la fusion bourgogne franche comté c'est
un formidable atout pour la france
comptez qui a un déficit d'image par
rapport à la bourgogne associant les
deux candidats voilà il ya une force de
frappe au moins en terme de
communication une fois qu'on a dit ça
maintenant que mettons en place au
niveau d'une politique d'accompagnement
des acteurs du tourisme
et là c'est un chantier également avec
xavier mir point vous avez vu les
chiffres bourgogne franche comté
la durée de séjour des touristes 1,41
jour là on a vraiment du travail à faire
ensemble
s'agissant de la promotion de
l'entrepreneuriat troisième chantier
mutualiser et que l'on va mettre en
place avec avec la cci 21
et puis pour en terminer à un gros
dossier parce c'est un enjeu le député
yann riou me le rappelait tout à l'heure
la reprise la transmission d'entreprise
nous avons un dispositif dans la chambre
du doubs qui fonctionne bien que l'on a
étendu au jura et au territoire de
belfort à auto et là on va le mettre en
place avec le 21 alors je vous frotter
les uns des autres
du travail formant delà de toutes les
postures ce c'est la mise en marche des
acteurs sur le territoire c'est pour ça
que je parlais qu'est ce qu'une région
c'est la fac la capitale c'est la
faculté de faire travailler ensemble les
territoires il est ensemble
vous parlez les 1/4 ya aussi justement
ces villes
besançon et dijon on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui elle se tourne le dos est
ce qu elle pas vraiment mais travailler
ensemble très concrètement juste pour
pour information on a essayé de réunir
les deux maires sur ce plateau ça n'a
pas été possible
donc est ce qu'aujourd'hui les villes de
tourner le dos rond
je pense pas qu'elles se tournent le dos
et moi je vais rejoindre vite fait ce
que vient de dire de me croire dans la
construction de la région n'a fait la
même chose à la cgpme on a réuni huit
départements et on appris ce qui se
faisait mieux dans chacun des
départements et on l'a mis pour tout le
monde et il ya donc une discussion donc
la construction des régions allaient
possible n'y avait pas de dualité
franche comté bourgogne on appris ce qui
se faisait mieux il n'y a pas de dualité
entre les deux maires je n'y crois pas
et aujourd'hui on stigmatise sur un
élément qui ne ressemble à rien une
guéguerre qui mon avis n'a pas de france
donc il faut demain que cette guerre
s'arrête puisque
là encore on appris ce qu'il y avait de
meilleur dans les deux camps est pour
moi le meilleur criminelle de commerce
pour recevoir des affaires spécialisé en
ta compétence était était dijon a
compris maintenant c'est l'exemple
concret lorsqu'on prend ce qu'il ya de
mieux dans les deux parties dans
l'occurrence il faut qu'on accepte de le
faire quand c'est du côté de la
franche-comté quand c'est du côté de la
bourgogne en lui il ya eu des choix qui
ont été faits en faveur de la franche
comté et on n'a rien on a en a pas on
n'a pas eu de royal sur en bourgogne
aucune la directrice de tourisme
aujourd'hui à la région et franc
comtoise je crois à elle été nommée hier
où le directeur ou la directrice c'est
quelqu'un de franc et après c'est trop
bien le président voilà non mais c'est
parfait c'est parfait donc aujourd'hui
voilà il n'y a pas de dia pas de débat
faut qu'on avance
parce que si j'ai demandé un certain
nombre de fois qu'il faut ça serait bien
qu'on arrête de parler du tribunal de
commerce spécialisé je suis d'accord
mais on a parlé tout à l'heure et
dominique roy l'abordé avec beaucoup de
justesse
essayons parce que on sortons un petit
peu de ce débat de rap pâquerettes s'il
vous plaît et si on donne un petit peu
de hauteur à l'ensemble arrêtons de
penser le cette antinomie dijon
bourgogne qui sincèrement dijon besançon
elle qui sincèrement me semble un peu
dépassée la cas pour le nab sujet dans
des accords pour la lazio
mais je pense que tout à l'heure j'ai
entendu des gens parler d' arrogance je
crois pas qu'ils aient d'arrogance
il ya eu des malentendus ya eu peut-être
on a pu même entendu parler d' arrogance
de dijon par rapport au reste de la
bourgogne
on peut parler d'un revanche de tous par
rapport à tout le monde franchement
aujourd'hui ça ne me semble pas un
dossier et c'est pas intéressant
moi ce qui m'importe aujourd'hui c'est
de dire ça construisons vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure de cette fameuse
métropole dont
on a parlé tout à l'heure dont monsieur
m'a permis on y revient oui et bien déjà
la première des choses et c'est ce que
disaient leur envie on ya quelques
instants développons déjà un système de
transport qui est pour le moment encore
insuffisant parce que les biens et les
personnes ont besoin de ce contact et de
d'être rapprochés les uns des autres et
c'est la première jour on n'empêchera
pas il y aura toujours le doubs 1 entre
les deux la saône
ça sera toujours là je crois y aura
toujours la même distance entre les deux
villes
favorisons effectivement déjà les infra
entre les deux les deux pour le crois
que ça fait des priorités du conseil
régional ont maintenant mais plus
généralement action nous sur les deux
forts à les forces de nos deux régions
parlons par exemple du véhicule du futur
parlons de des pôles d'excellence de
magny cours et de belfort montbéliard
ça ça m'intéresse parlons de ce que la
bourgogne peut apporter à la franche
comté et la franche comté à la bourgogne
la bourgogne à travers sa notoriété bien
évidemment son vin c'est sa culture vini
viticole qui est connu dans le monde
entier
la culture industrielle et commerciale
de la franche comté dont la bourgogne
doit pouvoir profiter
mais bon sang de bonsoir c'est l'un où
on a des forces à développer c'est ça
qui m'intéresse
le tribunal de commerce spécialisé avec
les cinq affaires vous arrêtons arrêtons
arrêtons
soyons positifs sur des vraies fait sûr
que les vrais gens à temps c'est-à-dire
d'avoir une vraie région
c'est notre objectif commun bien
évidemment un certain nombre de prêts
entre les mots et la reine ont requis
d'organisations dont nous avons la
responsabilité pour que cet élan puisse
naître pour que cette confiance soit
soit adoptée il ya un risque qui nous
guette tous si on n'y prend garde ce qui
explique les réactions que je comprends
que vous n'aimeriez pas bien ce qui
s'est passé entre le changement des lots
et à besançon
je crois pas du tout c'est normal de
depuis dijon je ne vais publier le
détail on l'appelle h que ça c'est ce
sentiment
des territoires en général alors ça
peut-être de besoins cent par rapport à
dix jours de la franche comté par
rapport à la brune mais pas seulement sa
plaie de la haute saône par rapport aux
doux ou aux deux juras par rapport à
besançon où delon sociaux n'est pas rare
besançon ou de l'yonne et de la nièvre
par rapport à tout en déboursant par
rapport aux villes plus grandes et des
territoires ruraux par rapport au bout
et c'est ce sentiment ce sentiment
d'abandon
ce sentiment d'abandon quand on paye
tous le prix politique aujourd'hui et
vous savez ce à quoi je fais référence à
d un détachement des citoyens de leur
rôle de citoyen voire une abstention aux
élections voire des votes extrêmes c'est
ce sentiment d'abandon et 7 ce sujet là
je ne cite même plus tellement et dati
cité il renvoie à ça au fait que la
république que la république n'est pas
toujours non seulement irréprochable
c'était le cas précis ici mais aussi
qu'elles restent notre république quand
même présent créé sur centralisme sur
cette centralisation voilà et c'est ça
cette nouvelle gouvernance et ça notre
défi en bourgogne franche comté plus que
dans d'autres régions parce que nous
restons une petite région de dépasser ce
centralisme pour aller vers tous ces
réseaux qui existent sur le territoire
et les réseaux économiques les raisons
la spécificité de la bourgogne sur
l'alimentaire l'agroalimentaire lé delà
de la franche comté sur les
microtechniques c'est tout ça qui va
falloir me rendre mais assurons les pré
requis et repris en la confiance qui a
été abîmé qui a été abîmé dans cette
affaire là et que c'est un accident de
parcours
je suis sur ce débat sera très utile
pour eux pour la seconde je voudrais
vous dire simplement une chose on est
une région vous l'avez dit petit on est
une région avec un petit pipi le pim
produit intérieur brut et une baisse
nous sommes une région en décrochage est
ce que vos portes et je vous rejoins
complètement lorsque vous disiez tout à
l'heure
moi je me permettrai de simplement vous
dire est ce qu'on a le temps de perdre
notre temps sur des choses qu'ils sont
peut-être conséquente pour certains ce
n'est pas tant que ça concentrons-nous
frais d'extension répondre à cette
question dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission parce que pour l'instant
on va faire une pause pour laisser place
aux flashs régional il est présenté en
bourgogne par lise région franche comté
par crise